belfast port the weather here not the
only misery the distance to get these
goods across the irish sea has not
changed but under brexit rules the
process to get things here has altered
fundamentally
for this midlands freight firm that
means more paperwork more checks and the
need for a lot more patience so for us
brexit has brought in many problems one
of those problems being northern ireland
and how do we ship to northern ireland
it's quite simply easier to ship goods
to south africa than at least to belfast
and that's just due to a complicated
process that was put in place
when the trade deal was actually done
but changing that means a big fight with
the eu the government has talked up
action but after the elections in
northern ireland ended in political
gridlock today it promised a new law
which would override the original brexit
deal coming soon i am announcing our
intention to introduce legislation in
the coming weeks to make changes in the
protocol
our preference remains a negotiated
solution with the eu to respond to the
very grave and serious situation in
northern ireland
we are clear there is a necessity to act
to ensure the institutions can be
restored as soon as possible the dup's
opposition to the protocol has frozen
power sharing in stormont a cautious
endorsement here the statement today is
a welcome if overdue step the words are
a good start but the foreign secretary
will know that it is actions that speak
louder than words
the situation in northern ireland is
grave businesses are going bust some
supermarket shelves are empty those are
the claims of the foreign secretary
but even though it can the government is
not going to do anything about the
issues it identifies for nine months
possibly even a year and it's unclear
how big a problem boris johnson thinks
it is and how much pain he's willing to
endure to fix it
the prime minister today was minimizing
the scale of the battle ahead we need to
address the problems with the
with the protocol
what that actually involves is getting
rid of some
relatively minor barriers to to trade
not all businesses echoing the prime
minister's case for change for some
firms in northern ireland the special
deal means the best of both worlds and
they don't want politics to intervene
the protocol has provided us with the
means to
almost trade as if brexit hasn't
occurred the consequences of that as
it's increased or traded into the
republic of ireland but into other areas
of europe
the prime minister must choose a big row
with the eu that risks costing everyone
more or a compromised deal with brussels
which risks the wrath of unionists and
hardline brexiteers a dilemma of boris
johnson's own making samcote sky news
westminster